I'm sitting here funny funny one of the
funny actress one of those funny
actresses yeah Ellie Kemper
I always remember your name cuz I just
think Ellie yeah like lacrosse lacrosse
oh yeah yeah they camp out in like 8th
grade that's how I would sign my notes
of course it was letter L II figure it
out let's see the dance from that movie
here oh do you know what I'm talking
about
no it's at the end you don't do it uh oh
just abuse me hey I haven't seen it very
I read that you studied with Jon Hamm he
taught an improvisation class he did
have mine in ninth grade
Donnie drapes Donnie drapes is that sort
of an incredible story that is so lucky
that that happened but he went to my
high school he came back he went to
college he came back and taught theater
for a year like can you believe I mean
you are feeling jealous now I am did he
have Donnie drapes here no no no he had
more boyish it wasn't gelled you know it
was free it was
twenty-four-year-old hair whoo okay he
was born he wore like boots ha ha I just
remember boots coming down the hallway
and all the girls will be like it's
going it's good ham is on the way he's
on the road I try and do a Don Draper
impression but it's just speaking lowly
killing ready you be Betty Draper
and then I'll just say what he says
whenever she says something difficult
Don what's going to happen to our
children Don what do you want to hear
that's really good wait you do that's
really good
you do want to have kid yeah isn't that
terrifying
I know yeah it's so terrifying it's a
daring but everyone does it like much I
know a lot of people do it like death
but that is a fine way to put it and it
is accurate and as someone who hasn't
had a child I can't think of anything
more terrifying and I'm supposed to be
like oh I'll never know what that's like
thank God
I know cracking and people like hand me
the shoehorn but the vagina one yes
bring in the vagina shoehorn you want a
girl oh you just you suggested that you
know I'm fighting out a girl but you got
a girl vibe can I say something
yeah yeah do all mothers kind of feel
like I really hope it's this one gender
and then if it's the other gender are
you disappointed cuz in six months I'm
gonna see you with little Lucy the
disappointment that you just yeah Lucy
she'd be lucky if she got that name yeah
it'd be like just learn this is blern we
wanted a sportsman let's play kill Mary
but only with Leonardo DiCaprio really
be caps Leo and Titanic Leo and Romeo
and Juliet Leo and Django well I am
going to marry Leo in Titanic Hobbs
Hobbs Hobbs um I hope yeah in this
situation he stays alive yeah I would
leo in romeo who and Juliet but here is
why yeah
I have not seen Django you're gonna that
one oh you're gonna go see it come back
and give you different am i oh you're
gonna feel the tickle of his whiskers
here we go here's a question for you oh
man
right well this this was obviously a
delight le feet thank you are you a
hugger yeah it's coming in hot
oh and I'll take it home thank you thank
you it was so great gabbing with you
here's a card for you to take with me of
course
the money well you can do that too